congress
right
is the only part of our government
per the constitution
that can declare war
how is it we've been at war for 20 years
what's the point what was the point
right because in in
jalalabad which has been considered for
10 12 years now a hot spot right
but in
january february march of 2002 i was
walking around the market without a gun
i'd hop on the atv and jump in the truck
hop in the car with one of my troopers
one of my afghanis
run down wearing afghani garb
the biggest threat to me in that market
or anywhere in jalalabad or all of
nangahara province
was having the people
hug me too tightly that was the biggest
threat to me
or maybe a car accident because
traffic's crazy you know they loved us
they loved us so what happened
the conventional military showed up so
all the colonels and generals can get
their stars and their awards and get
their promotions
those politicians because let's face it
right
once you become
a certain level
whether it's enlisted or officer right
your career becomes that thing and then
looking out for your other
you know upper senior officer senior
enlisted we got to get them bronze stars
we got imp purple hearts our unit needs
medals our unit needs combat because you
know to become a general without a cib
in the army
in this time frame you got to go get
some right and you're gonna probably
need a silver star at least a bronze
star would be
so how am i gonna do that unless i go to
war so let's take these strikers and
these m2 bradleys and
destroy roads and run over innocent
people and they weren't doing it on
purpose they're just that's the
conventional military they have tanks
and you know i've never driven a striker
before but i've sat in a hatch i'm like
how can you drive this thing without
running over everything you know and
they're like well you do run over
everything because it can
well you know what man we made those
enemies
we made the enemies then we're now
fighting the second generation we're
fighting the sons of the men we killed
in torabor
we're fighting the sons of the men we
killed in the shalika and hellmann and
everywhere else at the beginning of that
war
we created that enemy and the same thing
happened in iraq
and you know let's face it right
afghanistan was righteous you know
al-qaeda needed to fall i looking back
is it a good strategy
to topple regimes that are predictable
the taliban was very predictable the
taliban has never
met the requirement to be listed as a
terrorist organization they were a
sovereign nation
and yes they had horrible horrible
means and human rights abuses but they
were a sovereign nation
gaddafi
sovereign nation
iraq sovereign nation with dictators and
dictators are predictable they care
about one thing first and foremost their
main priority is their power so they're
predictable
you know in the interviews with saddam
you know he talks about like i thought
y'all were kidding
he was like i i thought you were making
it up that you thought i had weapons of
mass destruction i haven't had gas in
years i don't have any of that stuff in
his interviews you know he's going i
really didn't think y'all were going to
invade
so why did we
i have my own theories my theory is
because people say we went to war for
oil
i'm like
have you seen the oil prices
we didn't go football for oil we went to
war with iraq to stop its oil production
the prices went up
because if we had pumped oil out of iraq
you would have made all the oil
companies would have made money
right because that's a new source that
we didn't they didn't have
rights or access to
you stop the oil
all right
lower the supply demand stays at or
continues to increase
prices go up
so
that's a little bit of my theory on that
but whatever either way at least and
that's only based off of what i have
seen since right when we first invaded
that right
let's go you know like every other
little young trooper
but really
you know we're talking hundreds of
thousands of iraqis
thousands of americans and and what did
we get
right if you tell me you know because
war was supposed to be ex for expansion
um
minerals riches right throughout human
history war has been to expand your
empire
well we suck at being an imperial power
because we go to these wars and we do
nothing with the spoils
so why do we keep sending americans
because let's face it was it really for
our national defense or was it for our
national interests
because that's two very different things
most of my work throughout my life has
been for interests less about defense
because once al qaeda was destroyed and
eliminated and even isis and al-qaida
and iraq
were they ever really capable
of attacking us here
yeah you know they flew the planes into
those towers and killed 3 000 plus
people
but did they ever really threaten our
daily lives did they threaten america
the united states probably not
you know
right could they ever have brought that
war on a large scale to america and
affected the average american's daily
life
no they didn't have that capability
and after i mean clearly right like
none of that's really
we haven't had any big attacks since 9
11. i think they just blew their wad
they were done they didn't really i
don't think they had any plan after that
right he was like oh crap now what we
pissed these guys off and they're coming
for us
now what right they never really
did anything since
so my point is right like
where has congress been where has our
representatives in our senate been these
last 20 years
the military industrial complex
continues to make big time money
big-time money
when our enlisted soldiers are in
barracks
that are covered in mold just nastiness
right they're living in poverty
whereas you can go to the general's
house on any post and it's a
well-groomed
lawn and it's basically a little mansion
right
so so what did we get out of these wars
well
it's arguable right it's very arguable
but the bottom line is
congress
has continued to set aside its authority
its duty its role its responsibility
to either declare war or cut the funding
they didn't cut the funding a lot of
people got rich off these wars and i
mean i was a contractor i
guilty i
i got paid for going to war
now did i get paid like glock or
you know northrop or raytheon or
no of course not